feedback
after these messages
it's time to relax
it's time for something special
the bill we
okay we're back on youtube
hey
kids
tonight
you may be doing bro you missed my
[ __ ] rant
i went off oh it was crazy and you know
thank god
uh it wasn't live because
are you sure we're live
yeah
youtube.com
kevin smith
live you so is it the same page or
uh
page
uh not the it's like a new
um it's a new link
yeah the old one
so now there's two different ones
yeah so the old show exists as like an
hour and 45 minute show and now this
will be
part two
i still don't see us
i'm dancing
here i'll chat you i will chat you are
our link you can go there
if you look in the zoom chat
people are like hey
hey pay attention to us we're here we're
here to watch you
there's 228 people watching now my god
you're right we are back yeah
2 46.
[ __ ] scratch my balls i'm glad that
i've looked
all right kids we're back
giant tommy lee dick
yeah [ __ ] let me tell you something
if i can get one of those and wear it
like i bet you my wife would be like all
right
anything's better than what i normally
have to deal with he's like oh you don't
have to wear pants
kids the the the conspiracy is real
uh i spoke about spider-man not being
nominated by the academy
and we got tossed off of youtube
tie those two things together the truth
lies somewhere
out there
[Music]
um all right back back to the uh news
man back to the news should we just skip
over the oscars at this point for fear
of uh of angering the gods yeah we don't
want to [ __ ]
they got real [ __ ] real pissy about me
not you know about me talking about how
denny villeneux should have been
nominated if you're gonna nominate film
best picture yeah gotta nominate the
director kids it's that simple didn't
happen by accident
yes yes no it didn't particularly that
one
like we know how hard he worked on it
like he [ __ ] told us constantly like
it was very wow
like what is what are they trying to
teach them a lesson what the [ __ ] that
all about i don't get it
i don't get it don't make it um
yeah so moving on from the oscars which
got more sense
dune did well uh nightmare alley got
four nominations don't look up got four
nominations tell you something that
nightmare alley what a picture man
that's a movie it really is we did an
episode of uh film school fridays about
it um and deep lives on it me and
children the guy that did the
the uh
the guru the skew i've decided the movie
that i want to do what is it
streets of fire
um that means we have to be able to like
also deep dive on the rest of walter
hill right yeah
so that's gonna be easy
[ __ ] yeah i look forward to that
um also you know what's coming up what
is today february 9th
um 17 no 16 days from now yes is uh
february 25th and that will be the
four-year anniversary of the day that i
nearly died from a massive heart attack
celebrate i'm doing hollywood babylon
with ralph garman
on february 26th saturday night yeah
okay tickets at
csmodd.com ladies gentlemen over
flappers
in burbank it's a good space that we
should do to think about doing a
live show oh we got a show we got a
venue
listen to me i was better to jump ship i
was like hey man we should do batman
beyond something but the banff man is
like you do fat man beyond some place
he's like [ __ ] don't break up
with me on the air
uh but i think i think we can also we
can also tee up that event
on the the 22nd i believe which is when
we're back in the cantina is that what
we're doing we're coming back on the
22nd i think that's what we talked about
last time is back are tickets on sale
no but i can put them up on still
tomorrow should we do it
the omicron has faded away enough that i
think we could probably pull it off
california's gotten rid of mask mandates
but uh yeah los angeles has not
what day
tuesday the 22nd
you're looking at the magic wide open
this is how it happens this is how we
schedule the future
there it is people on twitter kept
asking me and i said watch the show i
bet you will do it live and we did
okay we'll do it live make sure you get
tickets we'll remind you before this
show's over man tickets you can get at
csmod.com or wherever uh banff man sells
his tickets where's he sell his tickets
uh eventbrite eventbrite eventbrite
that's it
um all right
those guys
did i hey did i get a nomination you did
not yet then what do i give a [ __ ] move
on moving on um were you a futurama fan
at all i watched the first season uh you
know more respecter of course i've
watched more simpsons than futurama but
i always dug fair um well it's coming
back um
hulu has finalized deals for 20 new
episodes of the matt greening and david
x cohen uh sci-fi comedy futurama which
will premiere in 2023.
[ __ ] i man
um
much of the original cast is coming back
billy west katie seagal
tress mcneal maurice lamalsh
lauren tom and phil lamar and david
herrmann
there is one
original cast member who to date is not
returning which is john dimaggio who
voiced the foul mouth robot bender
apparently there was some some
negotiations that fell apart
um
and so i think they're still trying to
make it happen but to date it isn't so
they announced they announced the show
without him being a part
this is apropos nothing but can we give
a little [ __ ] side love to naughty
chewie
um boba fett what's his name
chrysanthemum
naughty chewy
uh getting like [ __ ] blown apart in
the streets of [ __ ] most zespa or
whatever the [ __ ]
was heartbreaking [ __ ] man i was glad
that uh spoilers that he made it
well i mean when when i spoke before
about
people being not good at their jobs and
not acting overly competently eight
dudes with knives start walking very
slowly towards a giant [ __ ]
wookie with a gun
who doesn't shoot them it's like what
the [ __ ] are you waiting for they all
took their knives out dude start
shooting them
and they all get close enough to start
burying [ __ ] in his back and like yeah i
felt for him but also
you you got to shoot these guys bro
not soon enough not effective enough i
mean yeah he he gets that moment where
he comes back with dudes like hanging on
his back and [ __ ] but like didn't have
to go that way bro
chewbacca never would have let that
happen that's all i'm saying
i don't know man i'm here for naughty
chewie
the black chew not the blue chew the
black chew naughty chewy man
um
all right what other news what news mark
um marvel uh by way of sony and by that
way i mean sony is hell-bent on making
their spider-man universe a thing yeah
to the point where
uh dakota johnson is in talks to play
the title character in madame webb
madam webb a character that stan lee
based on his beloved wife joanie oh
that's so sweet yeah yeah
uh she's always been an older lady in
all the depictions i've ever seen so
this must be some sort of
origin story indeed or maybe they're
just
revamping the character entirely
because i think they do want it to be
tying in to
venom and morbius and the upcoming
craven the hunter
which just added russell crowe to the
cast
um which suddenly makes that seem a
little bit more not that it didn't seem
interesting before but maybe a thing
that might actually happen now oh check
that out check that out so yeah sony is
very invested in making some version of
the center sinister six
um a real part of their undergoing
spider-man concerns
um there's no yet there's no release
date yet even
theorized for madame webb um but we do
know that
craven is going to drop on january 13
2023
so
just shy of a year
20 january
yep
let me show you
how much they already feel like it's
gonna be a hit my favorite craven story
though is craven's last hunt and they're
not doing that
no no i think there's still some ongoing
um debate as to how much tom holland
wants to be a part of this particular
spider-man universe
he's like oh yeah i will happily roll
with avengers but i'm not sure i want to
be in a venom movie they should [ __ ]
back up the money truck to that kid
right now and be like listen son
we'd like to buy your integrity
all of the artistic integrity you got
not much
there's not much cost [ __ ] truck of
money behind us and we're ready to back
it up and dump it right on your lawn i
just read that you bought a house with
zendaya
you're not cheap
so here's a truck full of that sony
[ __ ] money man some of that adam
sandler [ __ ] money
please
your man forever and ever and ever
you're just a boy make him a spider-man
playing for 25 years who are these
people that want to quit a role me and
muse could never understand it as you
know we've been playing the same
characters for 30 years
but whenever somebody wants to quit a tv
show jay is just like can you imagine
i'm like no
i was lucky enough to have a tv show
where i was on it for like five to ten
years i'd be like let's ride this [ __ ]
into the ground until everyone hates it
uh speaking of writing a thing into a
ground until apparently people keep
loving it
they're making a sixth scream picture
after the fifth one did uh rather well
at the box office
just this past winter
which we're still in the middle of but
it's hard to imagine that given that in
los angeles it was 90 degrees today um
it's still winter and scream did well
and so now they're they're prepping a
sixth one because why the [ __ ] wouldn't
you [ __ ] yeah
um
will beatty
in chat says jessica drew
just stays dormant where's the spider
woman movie
or tv show well like why would you jump
to madame webb ahead of like spider
woman
i don't know way cooler costume
and also not an old lady
yeah there's that
um even oh hey yes real quick because as
i'm uh putting our tickets up for sale
do you know
what
day we just booked a fat man beyond show
2
2 2
2 2
on a tuesday
oh my god harvey dente
crazy [ __ ]
february 22nd 2022 falls on a tuesday
deuce i made a show he's going to show
up and rob us with the [ __ ] uh deuce
gang and [ __ ] i made the tickets for the
show 22 bucks
instead
so outstanding i'll drop the uh
little ticket link in chat anyway if you
want to celebrate the ultimate tuesday
you know come to our show
yes it's only a two drink minimum
oh
[ __ ]
they see you gotta get a harvey dent
drink going for that day man
nice
call it the grace is that no it was yeah
is that what his [ __ ] wife's name is
in the cartoon
grace that's my [ __ ] two face from
the cartoon
nice grace oh
i don't know why they went with [ __ ]
aaron eckhart i could have rocked that
[ __ ] he would have [ __ ] killed it bro
chris dolan never [ __ ] calls me bro
he just you don't see me as the actor
that i see myself as
did you see [ __ ] speaking at
directors who are acting that steven
spielberg cast
[ __ ] david lynch in his new movie
i like david lynch the actor he's not
bad but he's on twin peaks and he's
always yelling
cooper
he's like listen i'm putting together my
uh my atom bomb movie
and i'm trying to think who i should get
to play oppenheimer have you thought
about kevin smith sir
well
not really but should we take a look
i would go to the audition in this hat
just to show them what a good actor i am
that i can act i can out act the [ __ ]
hat
i was like the hat plays they're like no
it doesn't
i heard you were making a movie about
fat man and little boy and i show up
every time there's fat man in the title
yeah you'll be hearing from my lawyer
um i i would uh
i would like to see i like when
directors act and i don't just mean that
you know because i'm a director but like
one of my favorite performances in
movies is martin scorsese
um in taxi driver
so unsettling in the back of the cap
like he out creeps [ __ ] travis bickle
in that scene
like you know where he's just like have
you seen what a [ __ ] 22 caliber gun
could do oh unnerving
but also he's so good in quiz show
he plays great head of the network or
whatever and he has that like real come
to jesus scene
where he like is honest with with uh the
dude from northern exposure rob morrow
he just [ __ ] puts it on front street
where he's just like people just they
just wanted to watch the money like oh
what a great performance man you know
you know okay no you get it you get
pretty good you know who else was
amazing director actor cindy pollock my
favorite uh real
actor
his he played dustin hoffman's agent in
tootsie and it's still one of my
favorite performances in a movie man
he's so good he was [ __ ] great
michael clayton and he was a great
filmmaker too but
directors man you could trust the
director to act their ass off richard
attenborough and jurassic park and [ __ ]
francois truffaut in close encounters
the third kind yeah spielberg is always
hiring [ __ ] directors he was almost
going to work with
lynch if i remember the story correctly
on the season two opener of twin peaks
like uh steven spielberg was going to
direct it but then lynch was like i'm
going to do that one myself and it
didn't wind up now
spielberg nominated for another academy
award for the west side story
that's right be careful don't talk
oscars we want to be here for a while
boy like that you kill your brother
i'm gonna dance gonna dance like it's
the end of the world
the officer krupke
do they do officer krupke in the movie
they do
do they really yeah
i mean like i love that song but it
seems like you know if i if i were to
imagine them cutting anything it was
like probably that
yeah because it's not about tony or
maria it's just about these knuckleheads
who run up into the [ __ ] precinct and
then escape by dancing and singing but
everybody loves it
yeah the office of crapkey we're really
upset
we never got the love that every child
thought i get
what is it we ain't no delinquents we're
misunderstood
deep down inside us there is good there
is good there is good there is good
there is untapped good like inside the
worst of us there's good
no no no no you know what i could have
done it i
have you seen it or do you not need to
because it's all in your head already
that's right it's in my [ __ ]
i have my own version of west side story
where i play all the parts
like i saw the west side story um
don't know it nearly as well as you do
clearly
well i remember the old one yeah and i
can't imagine they're that different
no
no more actual
latino actors latinx actors
less white dudes painted
brown
is that that's what they did in the
original yeah
yeah not a good look but also
hollywood
that was one of the illuminating parts
of many illuminating parts of the bill
cosby documentary we need to talk about
bill cosby that uh debbie kamau bell did
for showtime i watched two episodes how
many did you watch i've seen i've seen
three it's a really it's a really
riveting documentary yeah it's
extraordinary because it's you know it
does
it does the very hard trick
of
of giving you both sides of this picture
which is
here are the awful heinous things that
bill cosby did over the course of what
seems to be about 40 years if not more
and then
as a counter
interrogation it's
here's the good things that he did as a
human person who was concealing his
monstrous nature and one of them the the
the big discovery at least for me in the
first episode
was that for
the duration of hollywood before like
1962
there were no black stuntmen
you know without the one that i was like
i didn't know this story yeah i mean
there were like black actors who did
their own stunts like woody strode was
that guy who was in you know westerns
and stuff and i think jim brown probably
did a decent chunk of his own stunts
when he wasn't playing football
but
bill cosby for i spy was like you got to
get a black guy to double me because
what they would do is they'd find a
white guy and paint him brown
and you know they would also do that for
black women they had an interview with
this black woman who was one of the bond
girls for like live and let die
who says like yeah there was a throw
where roger moore is supposed to toss me
onto a bed and you frame by frame your
way through that scene that is a white
dude that they painted brown put it in a
dress and an afro wig
because they just didn't even think
about wanting to hire actors of color to
double actors of color that didn't knock
you actually they show that shot coming
down and you're like that's a man that's
totally a dude
um i don't even know how the hell we got
here oh right yes the the the painting
michael carteris or terrace whatever his
name was to play tony in the original
robert wise 1962 west side story
it is the documentaries what is on
showtime right yeah yeah yeah
documentary
but we have to talk about cosby we have
to talk about cosby um but
it's you know trigger warning it's
there's it minces no words
oh yes and then there's lots of
testimony
from people both original and native to
the documentary as well as clips from
other from other stories but it paints
the most frightening picture of a serial
rapist
um
that you might have ever heard
to show a term we never throw around on
this show very much but
that's what it's about the documentary
yeah that's it it's how does this guy
you know remain a shark
prowling the waters of not just
hollywood but everywhere he went and go
unnoticed for so long
very layered in terms of like
they really set the time
place it's a wonderful documentary yeah
which is like well made it's just
unfortunate like that it's about
subject matter that makes you go like
what what
even during albert what it's like my god
um anyway back to the news
i put this item in for me probably less
for you given that you've never seen a
fast and the furious movie
but
i have a pile of the movies that are
sitting here on my desk right over there
that somebody gave me you know to watch
in advance of us like during the
beginning of the quarantine like you've
got to [ __ ] watch these and then you
and mark could do a [ __ ] podcast
about it i still haven't watched them
yet i mean there's there's there's still
a part of me that wants to recant my
streets of fire and make my film school
friday be fast and the furious
i feel like
i feel like i won't have much to add to
the conversation
i'll
um
of course that would that would have to
then be a kind of series a very specific
like part one
episode one
fast and furious part two
of this installment is too fast too
furious we'd have to do all ten
otherwise what's the [ __ ] point well
what's the fast and furious news that
you're bringing to the table um jason
momoa aquaman himself
um is joining the cast for the tenth
installment um
he uh let's see plot details are being
muffled
but the aquaman actor could be one of
the film's villains
um
and this seems to be a sort of direct
response to
um the fact that vin diesel wanted
dwayne the rock johnson to return to the
franchise after skipping fast nine i
remember that yeah
whereas the rock was like no
i'm never doing that
and so now we swapped in
potentially i don't know what the role
is
probably not as the vin diesel character
but
we now have another giant
um wonderfully tan man
to be the uh
the the foil
for vin diesel's dominic toretto
it's nice that uh mamoa gets work cause
nobody will hire this man i know he's
just he's he's
he's just too frighteningly big and
handsome
i love to do
uh
i met him on a plane super nice kid yeah
i saw some story today just apropos of
nothing that this woman had a picture
she posted on on i think it was twitter
and it's from a convention like in
boston i think and it's her you know
standing there and jason mamola is like
hugging her like very closely clearly
this was like a pre-pandemic photo
and the description of it was
um
i didn't want to take this picture
because i didn't want
you know i didn't want my wheelchair to
be in the picture and then jason said
well what if i just hold you up and she
said no no no that's too much like i'm
you know i'm not a small person and that
might be a lot of weight
and he goes i'm very strong and so the
picture is just him hugging her for the
photo
and the idea that he was like you know
absolutely we're going to do this we're
going to get you on your feet you don't
want the wheelchair we're going to take
it out of there we're going to and it's
going to be this very intimate lovely
pose of these two people and she was
like i've never forgotten how generous
he was to do that for me um i was like
that's a good [ __ ] dude
it's good for you jason and moa i'm
gonna be a good dude good dude
um we have two final stories
um one is a birthday
and one is a farewell
which would you like to do first
and on the good note which is birthday
yes so we'll do death day first death
day rest in peace
that they i have nothing to do with this
project but there's a
masters of the universe live action
thing that's going on and they hired
some kid to play he-man
right yeah because noah said centennial
i guess who initially was cast as
probably he was but he dropped out and i
think he's uh
isn't he in uh
um black adam i think i think so yeah
um
but yes i don't know the name of the
actor i'm sure somebody will throw it up
in chat
um
let's see
yeah uh while we wait i have a bit of
news and i know we don't typically talk
about sports here but did you guys see
the french figure skater his name is
adam i'm going to butcher his name adam
sai him fa
who did his entire routine to
star wars music
and at the end they played a lightsaber
sound effect and he did a
lightsaber
mime the lightsaber move
it was
like youtube it after the show ends it's
incredible you
like
it's like it was before the alex it's in
the olympics the guy did like a four
minute routine to star wars music
imperial march the whole thing all the
way through it's pretty awesome wow
i would totally watch that yeah that
would like make me watch the olympics if
somebody told me in advance somebody's
going to dance to star wars music
they're like oh now i'll watch yeah [ __ ]
yeah give me that [ __ ]
uh but i live in california so i see
people who are in shape and much
healthier than me all the time i don't
need to turn on a tv to see people
halfway across the world being better
looking and more in shape and healthier
than me
i will say you know i i dip in and out
on the olympics my favorite event of the
winter sports
is the assassin training have you guys
seen this it's the
where the they ski and then shoot yep
yeah it's the biathlon and it's like you
know what they're all training to shoot
james bond
[Applause]
they did that in a movie man they did
for your eyes only for your eyes only
there was somebody was doing a bible on
and he started shooting spawn
and right then and there i was like i'm
never playing sports see that's what
happened that could totally happen um
but i like that's that's my one sport
it's like yeah they're just training to
kill dudes and the olympics should be
nothing but training to kill dips make
them wear costumes if they're just like
batman and joker i'm there star wars
terrier in chat says uh kev are you
watching raised by wolves too
yes
raised by wolves is back on hbo max uh
the ridley scott produced show
uh ernest dickerson directed the first
two episodes this season
gorgeous [ __ ] show
very sci-fi this [ __ ] show
crazy sci-fi there's a flying [ __ ]
snake in the show like
it's nuts i get stoned and watch the
[ __ ] out of it man
um good afternoon
raised by wolves season two
happening right now
banff
so
you throw something out there and chat
chat yields uh
like uh i i lost the metaphor whatever
uh there was a figure skating duo that
dressed as joker and harley quinn i
throw the picture up look at this
yes i saw that
how crazy is that
that's the world we live in man how dope
where anywhere and and with all of this
stuff happening in the olympics they
can't nominate spider-man
her best picture
you're absolutely right yep um
kyle allen is playing prince adam in the
uh in the upcoming live-action movie
kyle allen who was also in west side
story
oh is he who's he played yes uh that i
don't know
does he sing hey g officer krupke uh he
might be in that scene
um they keep telling me in chat that i
got hummus on my mustache but i think
they're [ __ ] with me mark
uh i don't i don't see any hummus i
haven't it's probably just white hairs
kids i'm 51 i'm getting old but i
haven't had an hour so i don't think it
would be there unless that's a euphemism
it's like you got hummus on your
mustache what does that mean what kind
of young child code is that it's code
for commerce
it's not very creative you might have
wanted to do a second draft of that
anthony parone says he could see my
boogers now i know they're [ __ ] with
me can you see my boogers mark uh no no
the pets are clean
they're always [ __ ] with me they're
always [ __ ] with me um all right
who's uh who who died um douglas
trumbull
the visual effects visionary who played
runner before the advent of cgi
that came down
he did the kaleidoscopic finale of 2001
a space odyssey
creepy cloud formations and close
encounters of the third kind
blade runner
and tree of life
has passed at 79 years old
a legend 79 79.
he directed two movies on silent running
starring bruce during 1972 and
brainstorm
in 1983
starring natalie natalie wood and
christopher walken they were met on that
movie and that's when
christopher walken went on the boat with
her and robert yeah
what's his name
wasn't it no not conrad um
was it congratulations no no no what's
his name robert
you know he was heart to heart yeah yeah
powers and robert
[ __ ]
but anyway yeah they met was on that
movie uh
forrester
no brain
brainstorm brainstorm robert wagner
that's exactly there it is
um yes
um trumbull had over the course of his
career got three oscar nominations um
for close encounters for star trek
and for blade running the motion picture
indeed wow vijay and blade runner well
we all knew the blade runner one yeah
um at one point
um
he was asked to do star wars
but was busy doing other things
and he never came back into it
never came back into it
um
kevin west in chat said rest in peace
howard hessman yes absolutely dr johnny
fever died while we were
away we didn't do a show last week um he
was my neighbor he lived right up the
street
no
um i saw him let me i've lived here
oh
[ __ ] oh we passed the anniversary i got
to tell jen uh we
i've moved into this house on february
2nd 20 years ago so holy [ __ ] yeah i've
been in this house for 20 years what we
still refer to as ben's house because i
bought it from them um and i he lived in
it for like less than a year i've lived
in for 20. we still call it [ __ ]
ben's house fantastic tell you how
[ __ ] programmed we are for celebrity
right just like
well the most famous person's name
should probably go first
um but in any event why was i bringing
that
yes bam bam february
2nd
2022 20 years it's like it was meant to
be
oh [ __ ] should i tell you what my birth
time was jc can you do my astrological
choice
you're dialed in
but yeah howard hesman lived up the hill
and in the time i've been here in the 20
years i've been here i saw him
you know under 10 times but always a
nice guy and stuff whenever i saw him i
was like doctor
doctor
detroit doctor
he was in dr detroit
i hope so
i know that he always looked at me like
why is he singing that to me what is
wrong with that man
um yeah he was a legend he lived like he
lived you know one two maybe eight six
eight houses up or whatever the [ __ ] um
and maybe even less than that because
the houses are big and the properties
are big but his
between me and him was penny marshall
for the first you know 15 years that i
was here she was she was there as well
and it was and
over if i go out on my deck and look up
i'll see mary lou henner
on her deck looking down at me never
forgetting the [ __ ] thing she got
that steel trap memory you read about
and stuff
they had around like 2020 and they're
like what happened december like [ __ ]
19th
1968 and she's like oh i was wearing a
pink dress and [ __ ] we went to the
like she's got she remembers literally
have you never seen this no i have
totally
like of all the characters from taxi did
you ever think that it would be elaine
or you know mary lou henry's character
rather
who
who had the steel trap memory didn't
that's a total recall seems like an andy
kaufman or christopher lloyd kind of
thing but
i just like that you live on a block out
of a 1978 tv guide
i'm stealing that that's awesome
i always just say like i live in sitcom
central but i like that
it's crazy i live in a play i live like
where
like having those people as neighbors
even though they never came well betty
marshall came over and did a couple
podcasts and stuff but being like in the
same neighborhood if i go back in time
and tell young tv watching kev like
you're gonna [ __ ] you're gonna live
around the block from that cat up the
street from that cat you're gonna run
into that cat while you walk your dog
like all the time
it's nuts
anyway yeah
so that and so the so the death was
douglas trumbull douglas trumbull and we
added howard aspen
rest in power kids or as i say on
hollywood babylon which you can go see
february 26
at flappers meanwhile tickets at
seasmart.com
uh big bucket of win big bucket away
um the other one it's
every time i go on twitter and i see
some celebrities name trending
i'm always petrified that it's somebody
that i have incredible fondness and
appreciation for has passed away
as i thought when i saw john williams's
name trending the other day but in truth
it was to celebrate
the man's 90th birthday
oh [ __ ]
john williams who has scored everything
that you've ever loved um and who is
still working like he's he's working
currently on steven spielberg's next
movie the fableman's which did cast as
you pointed out earlier david lynch um
my other neighbor he lives around the
block see this [ __ ] house
um the fablemens is the 29th film
collaboration between spielberg and john
williams um and he's also working on the
score for the fifth indiana jones movie
which will be at the middle of next year
is he really yeah you do the score even
though
beth rogan is also in that um
fableman's yeah in the spielberg movie
um
tony man watch pam and tommy he don't
wear a prosthetic dick but he's a really
good actor in it
he's doing i was proud you know i've
worked of course with the
a young seth rogen on zach and miriam i
was always impressed by him then but
like i i was very impressed by his
performance in this he's
you know but he's been good he he's he's
always been great but like even on that
steve jobs movie remember that
wasn't he did wozniak and like he was
holding the zone against [ __ ]
that other dude with the massive dick
who's not thomas yeah fast bender with
the
vast [ __ ] bender yes he has no shame as
one saw in the movie shame
literally
i mean [ __ ] if mine was that i would
wear it around too and [ __ ] move you
don't have to no more though cause you
could wear a [ __ ] prosthetic dick
like sebastian stan
winter soldier you get to see his winter
soldier a lot but it's fake
yeah too bad i'm sure he doesn't want
that story girls girls like uh you know
what i don't know i'm gonna get into
that but like
the idea like
i guess it goes for either gender could
one be titillated by a [ __ ]
if you're looking at a sebastian stan
and he looks naked and you're seeing his
dick but you know it's a [ __ ] fake
rubber dick
like can you
get turned on by that or is logic
overcome where you're like well no
that's
he's wearing a [ __ ] costume i i can't
speak to it as a person who is not
actively turned on by dicks small and or
big
um mark you say that
but but i will also say that you're a
good storyteller and every good
storyteller knows you need a little dick
every once in a while
like willie my man willie shakes once
said yes that's the great shakespeare
set
all the world's stage and every once in
a while you need a little dicks in it
they're a little dick in it um there
there are there are there was a whole
generation of men who had it in their
head that they they would fetishize
a the mystical woman with a third breast
thanks to watching total recall
and like
that's 100
prosthetic not the thing that occurs in
nature and yet
captured the mind
of quite a young lad that's true
i remember when we had rsd when i worked
at rsd video we had a porn room like a
legit hardcore porn room man
and uh and the boxes were big as [ __ ]
and you go in there and you see the
artwork and [ __ ] like that and some of
the artwork was very graphic
um
one of the porns was about
uh like this
guy that had two dicks and i know
there's a guy in real life who has two
dicks and [ __ ]
um and he's legit
um but this was like the most obvious
fake
you know like [ __ ] one of those is
clearly rubber mounted to another
play-doh
i was always so curious like since i
worked the store i got to see who rented
that
and boy they were [ __ ] circumspect
you they were
you could tell the box was handled a lot
but like not a lot of people had enough
[ __ ] nuts to come up to the counter
to be like i will take the
two dick one uh generally it was women
very comfortable women who came in to
get born of various ages
like 30 to like
the one the one lady man misses
i forget her last name and probably i
shouldn't say it if i did remember
uh she was like 50 something and [ __ ]
lovely lady like total mom total like
lunch lady and [ __ ] but she would come
in and every [ __ ] three days and get
like a porn like
i assume her and her husband were just
watching i didn't i never asked her but
she'd read like a normal movie but then
she'd bring like the hardest hardcore
[ __ ] porn and one time she had that
double dick movie
that almost made me go like
who are you
i need to know more like i sell you milk
and i rent you videos but
you're a fascinating rabbit hole i want
to fall down
you're my mother's age but you're
renting some of the most hardcore
pornography the early 90s has to offer
yeah i remember i also worked in a video
store when i was in high school and i
remember the people who would come in
and rent the porns but they would switch
out the tapes inside the box
to be like well
i'd like to watch lady chatterley's
lover and then you'd open up the box and
it was just like you know dick
slappiness ball drainingist whatever
you're like oh dude
you can't just do that like well i just
didn't want to you know you know like go
get the other box
okay fine
um man they tried to break sometimes
people come in with their kids and they
try to like get pouring on the down low
and [ __ ] we put that in like jersey girl
but i remember that when people would be
like go get your movie and the kid would
go get a cartoon the [ __ ]
dude would reach his hand into the porn
closet [ __ ] pull anything out he's
you know in the way of like look i only
need five minutes i don't care what it
is
did yours have the uh the the beaded
curtain no we had a door that actually
but it wasn't no handle
um
you don't want any more biological
evidence of anything happening just
don't touch more than you have to touch
sir i mean i'm not one of those like oh
the good old days but like there's a
whole generation of kids that will never
know the porn room
they're like we don't need it we grew up
with pornhub but it's like yeah but
there was something kind of like ooh the
secret room
and also the work you had to do
to see a [ __ ] nipple when i was a kid
like
so
much work
like yeah we gotta you know timmy's
younger brother you know has an uncle
who just keeps play boys in the bathroom
so let's all go to his house and i'll
take turns in the bathroom like no
a generation of kids that will never
know
the [ __ ] joy of finding playboys in
the woods
thanks to urban development there are no
more woods hence no more places for
young
and also i don't know if playboy exists
either anymore yeah not too much but
yeah
yeah it's that's one of those things
that's gone too man and with it has gone
a skill set like it was a skill set for
that dude to reach in
and get a porn without even like looking
at it and stuff a skill set he developed
which now
he has no use for anymore yeah it was it
was it was hard to get hard when i was a
kid i remember her name mrs gardner
oh i loved mrs gardner because i was
like who are you
like what a what a mystery you are
you're a riddle trapped inside an enigma
yeah i look forward to mrs garden who's
now a principal of an elementary school
in atlantic highlands being like wait
why are all of you people hitting me on
the email he said what
the two dick oh i remember the two dick
porn you're right
that was noteworthy
um all right uh that's all the news
that's all the news and we ended with
happy news we did
john williams 90 years old and still
going strong [ __ ] years old the good
news is that john williams is older and
more talented than you'll ever be
yes
and we're all okay with that
i just want him to keep making [ __ ] that
i like truly
um wow so he's gonna do an indiana jones
score even though
spielberg's not directing but then again
i guess he did a star wars score even
though
direct i mean he did that and empire
strikes back
yeah
that's the sound of john gleams hey
banff man we're done so you better bring
those questions man
all right we got some questions uh the
first question is from the pocky punk
here we've got a new feature too we can
bring him in
the pocket
who is your favorite star wars character
of all time all movies tv comics etc
uh pocky punk likes chewbacca
oh good for you lucky bunk i have to be
honest when i was programming this this
afternoon i was like
well if i'm bringing it in do am i
erasing my need to be on the end of the
show
it's too small for a old man like me to
read just about
uh who's my favorite star wars character
uh hopefully not max rebo because he got
[ __ ] killed he got
they gave a specific shot
of the band right before it wasn't there
he wasn't there
i noticed that
wow they did that's so funny they did a
whole band shot and i was like where's
max rebo i think they did it because
they're like we're gonna kill all these
people but we ain't gonna kill [ __ ]
max rebo
i look forward to the uh inspector herku
parrot who shows up at that [ __ ] bar
to piece together who murdered the band
it's like there was max rebo he is now a
suspect yes
conveniently absence was a bombing
you're just saying that because he's
blue
you're blue um
favorite star wars character
um
i mean really the the
oddly enough the the the pool is not
that deep
you know for favorite yeah
you know like
and what do you base it on truly the
character or it's or the character's
badass look
right or is it the actor performing the
character or is it some combination of
all three
um
do you got one
do you like who you gonna choose
absolutely darth vader one of my
favorite characters of all time
i ain't talking about anakin skywalker
that's for other people
darth vader himself
and uh that's the you know the same
darth vader we saw in star wars empire
strikes back return of the jedi until he
took his mask off
uh the same darth vader we saw in in
rogue one
just killing [ __ ] people just
shredding them with the force
that's
a character is fantastic
will stand the test of time great look
[ __ ] you know cool powers
also uses a [ __ ] sword
laser sword um yeah darth vader for me
out of everybody in star wars boba fett
close second even after the [ __ ] show
um i've i've loved boba fett too long to
be like well
he wasn't in his own show like
um
as you can see i go for the
you know you're pro mask yeah when i
think of star wars that's what i think
of i don't think of like han luke and
leia and stuff like that i mean i know
they're there don't get me wrong but
they're not
that's you know
look they asked me my favorite was it
darth vader get off my dick don't you
nobody's on anybody's dick here
prosthetic or otherwise
um
i i'm uh i think i'm a han solo guy
i think i'm a han solo guy i mean i i
i for me and this is all purely favorite
not best
and for me it's it's
it's all about that swagger and it's all
about the fact that han solo barely
knows what he's doing any given moment
but just like figures it the [ __ ] out
you know and if he can't
oh that's here
oh [ __ ]
um
you know i mean less so in jedi like i'm
less fond of the han solo that we get in
jedi um but i think that in star wars in
a new hope in an empire
like he's he's always
um
the the depth is above his head but he's
barely making it through and he makes it
through with flying colors
and and my favorite moment in all of
star wars is the millennium falcon
streaking out of the sun and han solo
saying you're all clear kid now let's
blow this thing and go home
like i just love it to death and my you
know runner-up is is lando calrissian
and i think i just have a soft spot for
scoundrels
that must be especially capes
[ __ ] capes dude he's other than darth
vader he's one of the only cape wearers
in the star wars universe yeah i mean
luke luke eventually trots went on but
with that too
well that does have that side kate yeah
it's a little jaunty
uh what'd you ban finn for to talk about
capes i just yeah i wanted to point out
you like people with capes and masks
fancy that red my head and heart my
friend
um
there was a uh thing that i wanted to
read you because it was oh lastborn says
wait your girl rosario's ahsoka tano
didn't get a mention
well i mean she got to mention when we
were talking about the show but in terms
of this my favorite star wars character
like ahsoka's
relatively new uh particularly rosario's
rendition of ahsoka
you know i've been watching [ __ ] since
1977.
so yeah it's darth vader man he's got
he's got quality and quantity just
quantity time on everybody
you might always have to [ __ ] answer
for this [ __ ] man can it just be like
whatever like that's you
that's you this is me i like prosthetic
dicks
i don't know if he'd be my favorite
character
my bar is low uh who is it bam fam
if i had to pick i mean i
it would very much be luke skywalker
from the original trilogy i
i've become quite uh
uh
you know
a uh i sing the gospel of jar jar binks
quite a bit from the prequel trilogy
but if like it's like the rando favorite
character i really like beau sheck
the guy who in the cantina obi-wan is
like do you want to take us to alderaan
and he's like [ __ ] no but talk to the
wookie like there's something so
cool about like the
guy who's just wearing an earthling
spacesuit in star wars
i'm playing john glenn
he's got the great sideburns like he
makes everybody else in star wars
sideburns look weak
he's the coward of the county like his
arc is that like he says no to everybody
until
finally he has to stand up and [ __ ]
i mean it's i promised your dad not to
do the things you had
i i would love to see that like the
short story about that dude's like
miserable life after he realizes the the
fair that he didn't take
it's like you know man you could you
could have been a [ __ ] general in the
rebellion man like then there's a
princess we're giving you a medal you
probably might have gotten a chance to
to to get with her you'd have done the
great things like [ __ ] no
stay here in this shitty place like i'm
making the safe choice did you guys
have you ever read this story this is a
true story there is a guitarist
in a seattle area guitarist
who joined this band and it turned out
he quit the band right before
alison chains broke
and then he joined another band and he
quit that band which turned out to be
nirvana
he was in like three of the biggest
bands of all time he quit all of them
and then he joined the army and went
into special ops in the army
like i feel like that's
your beausex story
it's a true story look it up it's like
the guy who quit
all these famous grunge bands i thought
you were gonna be like he went into the
army and that guy is elvis presley
like always jet another elvis factoid
he's like like the bass player in uh
that thing you do
you know
like a guy who just wants to be a
[ __ ] marine like all i want is like
come on they're going to be in this band
or two of the world's like yeah but i i
didn't list it
i got a [ __ ] army chad saying his
name is jason everman
jason everman who's jason everman the
the guy who is guitar player could have
been a millionaire three times over if
he had just stuck it out another month
appropriate name well don't rub it in
for him
joe and he's like [ __ ] [ __ ] you
like i can't believe they already got
got around to me took him 10 [ __ ]
years
mark did some math recently and figured
something out i did in this coming
september september 25th i believe is
the day will be the 10th anniversary of
my first appearance on fat man on batman
10 years 10
10
10.
like jeremy piven from uh gross point
blank very nice um i feel like we should
uh we should have a celebratory show
somewhere sometime
maybe at flappers and burbank
[Laughter]
i've got a baby to feed
um all right ma'am we need another uh
another question that was good yeah we
need two more
okay uh next question is from rockstar
wren
uh rockstar wants to know who should
voice grogu when he speaks
uh i think it should be gilbert
gottfried says rose
um that's funny um
no i don't think he should ever talk he
better not i was thinking about that
when i was watching the episode i was
like they better wait like 10 [ __ ]
years to let this
little guy talk because i just love his
cooling and stuff and you know they age
differently so there's no good reason to
like start giving them words
because then somebody's got to be that
voice one of the
worst uh
uh
you know letdowns my entire life was
when they
made snoopy talk
yeah worlds of wonder toy the snoopy toy
there was a talking snoopy i'm like
snoopy doesn't talk stupid guys
yelling at woodstock and [ __ ]
um so i don't ever need to hear same
with garfield man remember they gave
garfield the
at least the lorenzo music did kind of
sound like garfield felt
yeah and then bill murray and then bill
murray did sound like garfield was the
new garfield
i have no idea chris pratt
i think so
is i mean he was yeah you know i don't
know if he is also garfield he just went
for every uh lasagna eating character
like i got
long story short they better not [ __ ]
ever let grogu talk man like he should
be like maggie simpson
remember maggie simpson only said like
uh
dada or something it was elizabeth
taylor
i mean they've done 30 seasons plus so
she might have spoken since then but
i uh
my my vote is for oprah winfrey
as baby girl
no we don't know that goku is a dude
we've never checked under that [ __ ]
sack
i don't wanna maybe there's no sec there
bam i don't want i will i i will get it
in star wars just not as baby grogu
ahsoka refers to grogu as a he i believe
gender is fluid
it's true
um all right banff man
um
yeah you said nobody and i said oprah
winfrey there it is
all right
you get a spaceship you get a spaceship
get a spaceship you get get a spaceship
you do get a spaceship you do i love
that in the episode when he's like he
talked like that he talked to him
i loved him he's just sitting there
going like you remind me of a friend of
mine like
i mean it's great though it's great
because this is luke
who's luke's gonna talk to han solo
about yoda like i talked to this little
green guy and he's spoken riddles han's
gonna be like
what are you doing i'm gonna go shag up
with your sister
talking about this with me i'm gonna
talk to any skywalker it ain't gonna be
you
we are
i don't know what you were smoking on
dagobah but i'ma go [ __ ] your sister
so good luck with all that buddy
oh
jason mckibben in chat said tom waits
as baby as grover
um all right where are we going next all
right last question
uh scott nelson wants to know
what type of star wars character would
elvis play
well you have my attention scott nelson
uh what kind of character uh in star
wars would elvis play well number one
he'd have to sing so it would have to be
kind of cantina based or what was the uh
you know [ __ ] las vegas planet they
went to and you know
bite
yes
canto bit man that should have been ton
tons
remember they got those things with
human faces that were running around on
the planet and [ __ ] and he's like we got
to set him free or whatever the [ __ ] i
always felt that should have been ton
tons i'm not the guy that normally tries
to correct other people's movies and
[ __ ] but
why couldn't that have been tontons
very easily
my couldn't have been the planet where
all the time nobody there's not enough
tantown action in these [ __ ]
in the new star wars but maybe that's
maybe favreau and felony got something
planned they're like oh we're gonna give
you more [ __ ] tanzans and you could
[ __ ] shake a lightsaber out and split
them open and crawl inside on a chilly
night
all right well i have i have a
a compound question for you kev buyer
the question is what character would
elvis presley play in star wars
my
subsequent question to you is
if you're making star wars in 1962
who else is in that cast oh [ __ ]
um all right well i'm casting all this
as biggs
really
yeah biggs dark lighter is that his name
yes
he gets one scene in the in the
director's cut
[Music]
um
let me see if i'm casting elvis can he
be somebody who's already been in the
shows
absolutely like it would be like you're
starting from junk you're you're george
lucas making star wars in 1962
who plays luke who plays leia who plays
home
elvis plays
han solo for sure
um 1962 who plays [ __ ] luke um
and that's before i was even born but
like who
[Music]
why is it 62 again because that's about
when elvis presley was making movies
that's that's the the zenith of his
of his time
uh like there's there's a woman where
i'm margaret mia pharaoh as princess
leia could be as could ann margaret oh
that's good
i haven't thought of that
um
young frankie sinatra
that is luke skywalker
he could play grand moff tarkin
sinatra yeah in 62 he was still a young
man was he yeah he was always seemed
like an old man from the day i was born
um so he could play uh well
i don't know i ain't good at this
like we found the one thing
1960s actors i need to hear let me if i
had some [ __ ] help in terms of like
what was what was going on in 1962
yeah
[ __ ] check the elvis movie years
yes jailhouse rock is 57.
king creole is 58 gi blues is 60
and then basically all of the elvis
movies that you love
are in the early 1960s
in blue hawaii kid galahad girls girls
girls viva las vegas
roustabout
harem scarum
it is crazy how many movies this guy
made in such a short period of time
yeah i was going to say james dean i
feel like would make a good han solo he
would be right about
he's still around at this point
yeah he would have been like 31 i think
did he die right before that i think he
died right before that
can't we do elvis circa speedway
whatever you want baby that's 1968.
sure
all right ben kenobi is going to be
played by
paul schofield
thomas who wins an oscar for playing
thomas more a year later in 1969
69 um
let's see who uh
who's my princess leia
jane fonda is my princess leia
barbarella herself nice
um
uh for the droids i'll take uh
uh uh
uh abbott and costello
they might have been gone by that point
um now who do i want is my droid of my
british voice 1968 michael caine young
michael kane yeah it's all about alfie
i was going to go uh young peter sellers
but michael caine has a good poll
peter sellers man
um
elvis is my han solo all right 69 who is
my
who's my i'm gonna i'm gonna enter 1969
actors
i know who's my luke skywalker oh
robert redford
oh
good call
i agree that elvis is probably han solo
who was the most famous person in 1969
john glenn
like gave me who is the most famous
person born in 69 and it's daisy
okay that doesn't help
famous people no i don't want famous
people born in 69 i was one like
actors in memorable roles from 1950 to
69. ooh marlon brando we got to stick
him in a part
see granny
he's your grandma tarkin he's your
grandma yeah
evacuating our moment of triumph
clearly overestimate their chances
that's the worst [ __ ]
marlon brando he was
um
you could still have james earl jones as
darth vader because he was acting in
1969
and still had that [ __ ] voice
um
hmm
gregory peck wouldn't be a bad obi-wan
kenobi either
oh we forgot one of the biggest [ __ ]
movie stars in the world bro
charlie charlton heston
he was in like every [ __ ] movie in
this in the mid to late 60s yeah who
could he play
taylor
taylor as your
what
damn you
abby
another death star damn you
uncle owen and julie andrews is amburu
actors not in 60
68 man she's two by two like that's like
the sound of music [ __ ] mary poppins
country that's true maybe she's your
[ __ ] princess slay bro ooh she's
super pure yeah no doubt
but you know she can handle a [ __ ]
gun if she had to and [ __ ] shut all
those nazis
[Laughter]
i want to see your version of the
[ __ ] sound of music
that's way more [ __ ] metal than the
one my mother made where's the camera
pointing well they're singing songs
about ralph in the corner or whatever
but she's american nazis while the kids
are all performing she's like
she's taking out nazis in the back
rushing in and hit her [ __ ] notes
yeah a female deer
spray arterial on the wall
that was nice um was that our did we
answer i i think i think we answered
that we would both have elvis presley
play on solo we then just we went to
credit we went even further we did some
bonus work mark mark did another draft
of the question it got any better
uh i believe that's it
kids
indeed
banff man you popping up
um agent exodus said sidney poitier is
lando but i'm thinking more
i'm thinking more richard pryor
yeah
yeah i think i'm i'm going harry
belafonte
yes
yeah he's got style and stuff yeah
guardian doesn't but
now there's there's there's a little bit
more kind of sex swagger to harry
belafonte that wasn't there for sydney
i love it
banff man is that it bamf yeah that's it
you can't do any more show cause there's
no more show left to do
yeah
tickets on sale kids for the 2 22 22
return to the cantina return
of the jedi because jedi never take
revenge
um this is wild
come see us kids it's the harvey dent
show
22
22 tickets that 62 bucks
22 tickets
two drink minimum uh anything
if you missed that then the hollywood
babylon is 2 26
saturday night right over at uh flappers
comedy club and that's to celebrate my
four years of not dying from a massive
heart attack
[ __ ] you to death man so if you're ever
like i just want to tell death [ __ ] you
come the flappers comedy club
[Laughter]
what do you have captain splinter
um
well you know i have a i got a comic
book coming out on march 2nd
um
adora in the distance is getting its
print release that's right mark's comic
that has been had its digital release
for a while now is actually now dark
horse putting it out dark horse is
putting it out on the second of march
classy operation yeah and we we may or
may not have
an event that we can invite
fans of zeal podcasts to
um but more on that as details
emerge
um but we'll let the good folks know
nice and my campaign to get on seth
meyers is preceding a pace
that is my goal you want to get on seth
myers i love seth meyers yeah i i got to
be a big [ __ ] seth meyers fan during
the pandemic and i'm like you know what
i got a zoom account i got some fun
backgrounds i can put back here i can be
on your show from 1 20 to 1 26 in the
morning let me talk about my comic book
set let me tell you some [ __ ]
that's true and you do have a pretty
popular podcast that you know [ __ ]
not for nothing but you are a media
figure for heaven's sakes you know
he has authors he's had comic book
people he's had black dudes in his black
history month seth meyers
reach out
my big comic book fan too
i feel like there's enough things in my
favor other than a direct route to seth
meyers
uh i know people so i can uh i can
that's a
conversation that can be pushed forward
text jordan
what's extraordinary
um i'm not saying i can make it happen
by any stretch of the imagination but
like
we can get you a lot closer
six degrees of separation i will gladly
jump a couple degrees i love him that's
my boyfriend whenever i watch like i
will you know he drops [ __ ] all week
he's not on because the [ __ ] stupid
olympics
so i'm missing my boyfriend and [ __ ] but
when he's on i when i watch it on the
big tv jennifer my wife is always just
like oh look at you
you're in love with your boyfriend i was
like he's just so funny and and like
he's in good shape and
he's not wearing suits like now he's
wearing like relatable [ __ ] which
although he did wear he wore a suit for
david letterman which i appreciated i
saw that um but yeah i i like him
unsuited man i like casual [ __ ] myers
and [ __ ] yeah do you watch lobby baby
his stand-up special i did yeah really
good i did i find it
he he he hits this sweet spot that's
like
not hannibal burris who i also like
quite a bit and not
um
john mulaney who i also like but there's
this weird just little like this this
divot that he's found i'm like i'm gonna
be a storyteller i'm gonna tell like
long-form jokes that aren't really jokes
just my experience is doing a thing
um that are also punctuated with just
some amazing sort of one-liners classic
set up punchline jokes um i really
enjoyed it
i don't like him and i again it was a
pandemic it was him
stuck in his house
just kind of losing his mind slowly
you know and then returning to the
studio without an audience
and the like what happens when you're no
longer playing for laughs and then you
just get to be like
madly weirdly odd
and eventually the show he just did a
podcast yeah he's in a podcast by
himself the audience went away and he
was just doing a podcast like eventually
anna has a tv show but i love that i
love the home [ __ ] i love the no
audience [ __ ]
oh the no audience [ __ ] it's like you
really get away with jokes that like
they would think twice about doing with
an audience because like nobody's gonna
laugh at this yeah it got absurdised in
a way that i really appreciate it where
it's like suddenly scotland's as a
character
i'm gonna talk about my writers like
okay i'm the sea captain sure
um
russell cook says is the joint still in
his mug when i was on i gave him uh one
of my
one of my joints one of these joints
and um it's in
it's a snoogans this one's a snoogie
boochies but it's still in the cup
holder on his desk every episode i watch
i always look to make sure
it's still sitting there it [ __ ]
makes my heart sore each and every time
i'm like
it's still there we left it there and
then i'm baffled like who the [ __ ]
didn't smoke that by now
because it's now it's a shrine right
next to my doink fell off yes
i feel honored privileged to be in there
with the like the ephemera like the uh
the russian nesting doll of uh stefan
stefan and one of the characters from
his hulu cartoon
oh [ __ ]
the adventurers or something yeah
um all right that's my campaign to push
the book which we'll drop in early march
let's let's make it happen
like it happened somebody asked uh have
we seen the new jackass no not yet
um
but that's out now and making a lot of
money
you know it turns out that they were
right years and years and years ago with
america's funny zone videos that like
watching americans hurt themselves
is actually kind of fun
they were the internet before the
internet was the internet indeed
indeed um
we uh thank uh banff man for making the
connection between us and you sorry that
we
dropped offline for a minute there at
one point but sometimes technical
difficulties
uh do happen jinx and chat says what
role are you playing in the boys
diabolical that's right i'm voice on the
boys cartoon
i'm not allowed to say yet who i'm
playing but
yeah i did that
a long time ago and then suddenly they
announced it and i was like i am and
then i did that
oh my god that was that that was so long
ago yeah oh yeah and i wrote an episode
of the legend of vox machina critical
role legend of vox machina and i think
my episode drops this week i think it's
episode 8 hey man have you been watching
the show i have been watching the show
it's really fun it's really fun and i'm
always amazed you know especially the
dabbling in animation that we've done
that you were way deeper into it than i
was but just
how the process can be so laborious and
so painstaking and for there to be any
room in there for humor and timing and
and comedy is always miraculous to me
and this is a filthy funny show
um and i was very glad to get to play a
small part in it so yes this this week i
think they seem to be dropping them in
clusters of three and so my episode
should be in the next cluster so
tune in my friends vox machina indeed
the legend of vox machina
um
we give it up to old banff man brought
to us to your bandmate come in here and
get your properties come in here
there's jc everybody
[ __ ] uh husband quasi you guys aren't
married yet are you no we canceled our
wedding three times thanks to kovid well
you're practically i'm in law married at
this point yeah i we i mean
spoken for right
yeah i mean we have a baby a house and a
business together i think that's more
due to a simple category of husband
will you accept her husband sure he's a
husband he's a father he's a [ __ ] bar
owner he's like sam [ __ ] malone and
cheers for god's sakes but he's got his
husband and children
uh give it up for jc everybody and
[ __ ] uh there is no show without that
cat right there
i'm pointing this way you're doing it
you're doing it you're killing it
uh give it up for marvelous mark
bernardin later oh thank you sir look
forward to mark are the in the hockey
games at the end i don't know if they do
this in other sports but they pick the
three stars of the game
where the sports writers will be like
these are the three stars of the game
like did the
you know in pecking order they did the
most impressive generally it's whoever
scores or scores the most and then
somebody else scores and then maybe an
assist sometimes it's a goalie or
something like that
tonight's two stars of the game
definitely go to you and jc for your
back and forth star wars conversation
deep dive and third star of the game
goes to me for shutting up and not
interrupting
sticking to my new year's resolution yes
i i feel like i was just lucky to be in
uh be in the pool with jc
when uh doing deep dives into star wars
so it's like yeah i got to swim with
michael phelps like i didn't win
i didn't bet didn't even keep up but you
know what i was in the [ __ ] pool
yeah i like his show better than your
show it shows uh makes more sense
uh there it is kids
that
is fat man beyond for this week [ __ ]
three-hour show man hell yeah sorry uk
if you were trying to stay up and
listen yeah i mean
it's four o'clock in the morning
um let me tell you something kids it's
been a pleasure and a privilege and an
honor to sit here and [ __ ] with you
is about some [ __ ] that means a lot
to us and maybe nobody else
so
thank you for being i just got a text
from my wife saying good night what the
[ __ ] time is it
when did she turn into my
mother kids i gotta get out of here and
go wake my wife up real quick so she
hasn't turned into my mother
kevin it's been a day
it really happened
uh thanks for hanging out kids for fat
man beyond
i'm kevin smith and i am mark bernard
tuna next time same fat time same fat
channels podcast.com or youtube.com
kevin smith and a very big jeff's kiss
to all of you mwah
this is the cat
greetings everybody and welcome to the
aka ask if anything every saga has a
10-year anniversary ladies and gentlemen
and this is what happens when jay and
sam bob get old i'm kevin smith